العديد من العاملين في الخطوط الأمامية يأخذونها ، وقد
أخذتها ، وأنا
آخذها الآن ، نعم ،
منذ أسبوعين ، بدأت في أخذها لأنني
أعتقد أنه من الجيد أنني سمعت الكثير من
القصص الجيدة وإذا لم تكن كذلك  حسنًا ،
سأقول لك حقًا ، لن أتأذى من
ذلك ، لقد كان موجودًا منذ 40 عامًا بسبب
الملاريا بسبب مرض الذئبة لأشياء أخرى
، أعتبرها عمال الخطوط الأمامية يأخذون الأمر كثيرًا
من الأطباء ، يعذروني كثيرًا من
الأطباء.  اعتبر ذلك ، ما
رأيك في سانجاي جيدًا ، لا يجب أن
تأخذه ، أعني أنك تعلم أن إدارة الغذاء والدواء الخاصة به
قد قالت أن هذا لا يزال شيئًا
قيد التحقيق ، ولا ينبغي
أخذه خارج تجربة سريرية تم
إخراجها من المستشفى ، أنا فقط
المرضى في المستشفى  يجب أن نحصل عليه ، أعني أنه
ما قاله عن حقيقة أنه
تم استخدامه للوقاية من الملاريا
لعقود من الزمان هو صحيح ما اكتشفناه
مؤخرًا هو في الأشخاص الذين
لديهم بالفعل كوفا بالفعل هذا المرض
أن هناك بعضًا حقيقيًا  المخاوف التي
تعرفها والمخاوف المتعلقة بالتأثير على
القلب ربما تتسبب في
عدم انتظام ضربات القلب ، مثل تلك الأشياء ، قال
إن هناك الكثير من العاملين في مجال الرعاية
الصحية الذين يأخذونها ، أعني
أن هناك تجربة لا تزال مستمرة في
معظم البيانات التي نعرضها.  لقد تحدثنا
عن الذئب الذي لم يكن
مثيرًا للإعجاب على الإطلاق فيما يتعلق بهيدروكسي كلوروكين
كان في الأشخاص الذين أصيبوا بالفعل
بالمرض بالفعل بالفعل ،
كان هناك هذا السؤال الذي طال أمده ، هل
يمكن استخدامه كوسيلة وقائية
لمنع الفيروس من دخول الخلايا في
المقام الأول  لا يوجد دليل
يشير إلى ذلك ، ولكن نظرًا لأننا حاولنا أن نكون
مسؤولين للغاية ، فأنت تعلم أننا نريد
تقديم الدليل كما حصلنا عليه
، لا يوجد دليل للقول بأن هذا
يعمل بهذه الطريقة ، حيث أن التجربة
جارية للعاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية الذين لديهم
أهمية كبيرة.  التعرض
والرئيس ترامب لا يتناسب مع أي من
هاتين الفئتين ، لذا فأنت تعلم أن هذا
أحد تلك الأشياء التي أعتقد أنها
ستسبب الكثير من الارتباك  الاستخدام في الأشخاص ، لكن
وفقًا لإدارة الغذاء والدواء الخاصة به ، يقولون إنه
لا ينبغي استخدام هذا خارج
تجربة سريرية أو للمرضى الموجودين بالفعل
في المستشفى ، وآمل ألا أعرف من الذي
وصفه له ، فهو
دواء بوصفة طبية وآمل في ضوء ذلك
لديه تاريخ من أمراض القلب التي
تتم مراقبته بطريقة ما حتى
لا يعاني من مشكلة
، لا أقترح أنه سيعمل
كدواء وقائي ولكنك تعلم أنه من
الواضح أنه يجب أن يكون حذرًا